Mary Poppins, first movie
Instant Oscar, did that kind of skew your life that you, cause getting an Oscar is such a big deal, Reese, hello
But to be that famous suddenly, did it hit you like a bulldozer? Yes it did yes, it did indeed. No I think
It sent me into therapy and analysis. Mm-hmm, all of that because it's like oh wow
What's going on? Cause Reese, obviously you won the Oscar for Walk the Line
But was there, did you have a moment in your life when you kind of think
Oh, I'm actually very famous now
I remember, I actually I was here in England doing The Importance of Being Earnest
film and then Legally Blonde came out in
America and it made all this money and I went back to America and my whole life had changed
There were paparazzi waiting at the airport. I had a little baby. I was completely terrified
But did anyone warn you? No
Like before you
You can't know, people don't know who's gonna become and you don't know why you're the person that, and you don't keep a light
You don't know it's going to be a huge hit. Jennifer
There's a famous picture of all of you guys all the Friends cast on a plane. I think you're being flown to the Vegas. Ohh
Yeah, that's correct. That's what Jimmy Burrows who was our director, a very
Fantastic, infamous television director took us to Vegas and took us to dinner
At Caesar's Palace. It's very fancy
And said, told all of us to, basically, said I want you guys to all really look out for each other
Because this is probably gonna go on for a long time
And he said, so the most important thing is to look out for each other. Take care of each other and
Then he gave us each a couple hundred dollars, and he said now go into this casino and enjoy yourselves
Because it's the last time that you'll have your anonymity. That's interesting. So we didn't know what the heck that meant. So we
But it really kind of was
Because once that. So someone did sort of prep us but then again when it happens, you know, so you still think it's so weird
It's all the touring and trips. Yes. I I mean not that one should ever knock it. Yes
It's part of being you know, it's a huge gift. Yeah. But it is a lot of obligation
It's strange when someone comes up to you in the aisle of a pharmacy and you're buying toilet paper. I know.
And then they're like OMG can I get a
Oh I, excuse me. There's a fabulous story about my little Emma and she was about
three and she was taken to the tussacks of the local sacks where they had a huge display of
cardboard cutouts of Mary Poppins and everything, she said
Oh look, there's mummy and she suddenly heard two ladies say 'isn't that sweet, that little girl thinks Mary Poppins is her mummy'.